welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of miss
marvel episode 2 which teaches us all a
little something about pretending you're
crushed as your cousin when we're in the
wish fulfillment genre it may just come
true and hey we don't know that for sure
yet which is exactly what we say at
family reunions down in the south let us
break down this episode shot by shot for
all the mcu easter eggs and details you
missed and thanks to boxsu for
sponsoring this video more on their
tasty offerings later and the best way
to support new rockstars is to get our
ms marvel inspired cosmic daydream shirt
at newrockstarsmerch.com when you get
this limited edition latest obsession
you'll get the added option to write in
a custom shout out for our miss marvel
aftershows notice how the s in the
previously on screen matches the s of
the ms marvel title in the comics and in
the series they intentionally stylize
that s to draw the eye to it make it
clear that she isn't a miss marvel like
little miss superhero but rather miz an
independent woman in control of her own
life the episode opens on kamala
strutting back into her school to maces
feel so good the course to which is bad
bad bad bad boy you make me feel so good
little tease of the bad bad boy komaron
whom kamala will fall for this episode
bad bad boy with ulterior motives she
wears a save ferris button say ferris
being a scott punk band who of course
got its name from the gag and ferris
bueller's day off where ferris faked
being deathly ill to get out of school
launching the save ferris campaign while
he rigged up a stereo in his bedroom to
fool his parents similar to how kamala
tried to use zuzu to trick her parents
into thinking she was in her room she
fools around with a basketball echoing
andrew garfield peter parker's post
power-up moves in the amazing spider-man
but then she bumps into cameron knocking
over her chemistry textbook as we saw
with peter and mj smooching beside their
chemistry textbook it's a little on the
nose come on where's the color blue and
with kamala's purple color tones there
definitely is some conscious wardrobe in
here as in the miss marvel comics
camaron gets hit with the same terrigen
mist that kamala does transforming him
into an inhuman with blue colored
bioluminescence where he can release
energy blasts or transfer his energy
into an object causing it to glow and to
explode this episode's ending reveals
comrade was targeting kamala from the
very beginning in league with his mother
najma and i would not be surprised if he
actually bumped into her on purpose here
either to plant a tracker on her maybe
list something off her or maybe just
test her power reflexes kamala tells
bruno i tried to shrink and and fly and
talk to ants and none of it worked wait
what makes you think you have ammo
powers because we're about charming and
we look a lot younger than we are an odd
to actor paul red's freakish agelessness
and the fact that in the mcu scott lang
bypassed the blip while he was in the
quantum realm making him older on paper
than he is biologically and at one point
in game he did have the body of a baby
and the fact that all of these mcu
actors blame teenagers are several years
older in real life than their characters
are they passed this poster with a qr
code which is also something we saw in
many episodes of moon night intentional
easter egg snuck in there by the marvel
studios team because when you scan this
with your phone it actually takes you to
an issue from the 2014 miss marvel run
actually this same qr code showed up in
episode 1 on the atm in bruno circle q
store and last week that code took you
to miss marvel number one from 2014.
this week the qr code takes you to
number 15 of the 2014 ms marvel run the
issue when kamala meets komron social
media star zoe zimmer quadrupled her
followers posting about her rescue by
kamala on tick tock and she brags about
it here in the cafeteria and then this
like
beautiful white light like cascaded over
me i felt this wave of calmness like i
knew i was safe okay i don't want to
read in this too much and you know we're
all probably going to come around on
zoey she's actually much nicer than she
seems right now but the one thing we
know about that hard light that saved
her was that it was not the color white
it had other colors in it i'm sorry zoe
i know you didn't mean to say it but so
he does [ __ ] the name night light
similar to and far from home when ned
had to come up with a superhero name and
came up with night monkey the opening
titles of this episode toggle through a
bunch of interesting designs first miss
marvel as brass knuckles the period on
the miz is the same shape as the
starburst icon on her bengal than her
car dashboard then a donkey kong style
game and a night sky with a crescent
moon evoking the moon knight title
imagery and then one in the style of
saved by the bell kamala makes a fist
how does it feel like an idea come to
life yeah another clue that kamala's
powers are a form of wish fulfillment
triggered by her inner desires and
thoughts also if this is innate to kamal
khan's dna that makes it even more
likely she could be an inhuman as she is
in the comics but rather than exposed to
terrigen mist herself she just may be
the daughter granddaughter and great
granddaughter of inhumans inactivated by
a piece of creed tech that could be what
triggered the pterogenesis process the
mural by the playground that they train
at was actual art created by new orleans
area artists and activists b mike
brandon odems and then kamala gets the
idea from watching bruno play looks like
the game lucky's tale to use her hard
light as a lily pad bruno's tablet
impressively tracks kamala's vitals and
is able to deduce from that that the
power comes from within her not from the
bengal meaning the bengal really just
unlocked the power that was already in
her dna from her family ancestry and
like we are wondering what that is
kamali begins to speculate so what am i
like asgardian or something dude am i
related to thor oh no i didn't say any
of that maybe while kamala is probably
not an asgardian like thor is she may be
something else extraterrestrial in
origin like an inhuman experiment by the
alien race of the cree she and bruno
noticed some writing on her bangle
kamala thinking it's either arabic or
maybe urdu but from our vantage point
it's not clear if they were talking
about the symbols on the green bands or
somewhere else on this bangle but for
reference we do know the alphabets for
the cree and the scroll languages and
we've also seen the written language of
xendarian in the guardians of the galaxy
movies so kamala experiments with this
lily padding on this hard light she
hangs on the ledge by that iron brand
poster that we saw last episode this
fake out with her and bruno acting like
she's gonna fall off the building just
for her to drop a few feet definitely
reads like re-staging of natasha's death
in in-game with bruno playing the
platonic ideal best friend clint i
assume an account of this would have
been in an episode of scott lang's
podcast for natasha now be on a memorial
poster an avengers con i would hope that
kamala would take a moment of silence
and she eventually gets the hang of it
the shot framing her within the bolt of
the neon edison sign just a cool way of
showing that she is now in control of
the hard light you think about it that
is kind of what a neon sign is it's
light but it but but it's hard it's hard
now of course in order to accomplish the
stunt of this shot they had someone on a
green screen set and then vfx them onto
this roof which is why that little
celebratory yes at the end just looks a
little weird oh and this edison sign by
the way is a reference to the inventor
that was kamala khan's first real
villain in the 2014 comics a cockatiel
bird possessed with the consciousness of
a clone of thomas edison actually that
cockatiel bird we saw among kamala
khan's drawings in the opening image of
episode 1 was also a nod to that guy
it's a little too wacky of a concept
probably for this show but i'm so glad
that they pay homage to him this way
kamala and nakia are late to mosque
services and we learn how the women's
section of this mosque is less
maintained we've got some crumbling
tiles in the bathroom mold under the
carpet less security around the women's
shoe racks because poor nakia gets her
shoes stolen maybe whoever that skrull
was who stole nick fury's shoes on the
squirrel space station got my shoes
scrolls might have a thing about
stealing shoes and we laugh about that
but i do think skrulls are gonna show up
in the show at least i hope they will
and my favorite detail this episode
later when kamala saves that kid from
falling we get a close-up of the shoes
and what do you know it was this twerp
who stole nakia's shoes the women of
this mosque have to deal with enough kid
onto zoe's party which becomes a pool
party because cameron does a high jump
into the pool super weird to do even
though this pool is heated because it is
freaking cold outside they're all
wearing coats they have these heater
lamps and now poor camera is gonna be
stuck in wet clothes all night as he
leaves this pool you can see some blue
light and blue mist steaming around him
definitely evoking that bioluminescent
form from the comics actually later
during kamala's fantasy sequence she
envisions herself in purple neon and
comrade in blue neon may be a nod to
them both being bioluminescent inhumans
i like how poor jealous bruno tries to
subvert cameron's coolness you really
belly flopped back there man that that
had to hurt i don't think so i really
feel the thing
nice try birdo ain't gonna happen why
because cameron clearly has them oddly
inhuman properties to his body and
kamala flirt by discussing their
favorite bollywood films referencing srk
that of course is the great sha rook
khan massive bollywood movie star and
they also mentioned two of his biggest
titles basigar from 1993 and ddlj from
1995. he gives her his number but again
as sweet as this seems it is too good to
be true comrade has ulterior motives and
was clearly assigned by his mother to
get close to kamala bruno was right to
be suspicious if things are too good to
be true they often are before kamala
doesn't know that yet because she is
smitten the lens dissolves into the
lights all forming these heart shapes
and then we get this adorable dance
number to the runettes be my baby and
again because it's my job to ruin
wholesome things be my baby sung by
ronnie specter produced by bill specter
though inspector was married to her and
did horrible horrible things to her look
it up so as sweet as things seem on the
surface there is actually a dark truth
behind them now last episode we saw a
similar fantasy sequence from kamala's
perspective of her whole family all
dancing in celebration of kamala but now
notice it is only kamala dancing as her
parents watch on from the kitchen
confused gala is joined only by the
beautiful vibrant lights now filling the
house because kamala's core relationship
in the series is really a dance between
her and her lights this fantasy turns to
neon forms of her and cameron drifting
off in his face joined by two astronaut
sloth babies this transitions to kamala
daydreaming at her desk and her nose
suddenly glows in an analogous scenario
to getting that surprise zit on your
nose in the middle of a school day
naturally leading to nakia what a great
friend handing her a tampon and by the
way i hope this was not the reason why
this show was randomly rated td-14
because you really think kids younger
than 14 aren't also going through this
kind of thing mr wilson tells bruno that
he got into early admission at caltech
but bruno isn't sure about jumping on
this opportunity you know that part in
the movie where someone comes in to the
main character and they say you want to
be a jedi or you want to answer phones
of a demanding but impossibly chic
magazine editor as before mr wilson only
knows how to speak to these kids in
movie references and in this case star
wars and the devil wears prada but
despite knowing so much about movies
wilson is failing to acknowledge that a
classic step in every protagonist's
journey is the refusal of the call luke
skywalker rejects obi-wan kenobi
initially and only leaves tatooine once
his aunt and uncle are killed until
where's brother andy initially walks out
of the interview with miranda priestley
thinking she blew the interview and
tries to quit several times before
finally deciding to take the job
seriously so bruno is at the refusal of
the call stage let bruno have his beats
so after school comrade waits for her by
his sweet ride and notice how the sun
glares off the hood blinding her with
the light again last episode all these
lens flares blinding lights representing
kamala being distracted and i love the
block in here bruno blocks that light
gives her a relieving shade trying to
keep her away from this bad bad boy and
shielding her from the blinding light
also you'll notice how bruno wears a
blue shirt and a red vest which is a
night to the comics when kamala had a
kid who sat behind her in class dressed
up as marty mcfly who doodled teen wolf
in his notebook cameron and kamala chat
some more about bollywood stars mine's
the same she still has a huge crush on
king of senior ew concerning fairy
they're referring to the movies of kingo
camille nanjiani's character in eternals
a bollywood star who would reinvent
himself as a younger generation era
after era cameron goes on to say yeah i
mean it must be a generational thing
because i don't really understand how
things my mom's into a very important
line when you consider the context that
cameron may be a generational inhuman as
well their ancestors having an
extraterrestrial link maybe najma was
into kingo knowing he is an ageless
eternal not originally from earth
pretending she is much younger than she
really is is something that she also
does amir catches them she's komron
he's our cousin
our cousin
the ending of this episode does imply
that they may actually be related
hopefully he's adopted because otherwise
why are you hitting on her like that
dude now i've heard from a bunch of you
new rockstars viewers that you have
already signed up for baksu but for
those of you unfortunate uninitiated
boxu is amazing it's a monthly
subscription service that delivers
premium japanese snacks and tea pairings
straight from japan to your door they
source rare snacks from all over the
country and partner with family
businesses to make their own signature
treats all of this curated and delivered
under a new theme every month this is a
box i got this month and this month's
theme is midori moments so midori means
green in japanese and this box reflects
the green rainy season in japan it's got
a wide variety of wasabi matcha and
fruit flavored snacks let's try this uji
macho waffle cookie
oh there's filling
it's like the perfect balance of like
sweet and salty
oh my god it's good that you just put
one of these in here because i need a
million of these things
and here's a little trick that veteran
subscribers like me know when you really
fall in love with the boxing snack you
can order some direct from their site at
a discount both i and the new rockstars
office have been receiving these boxes
and we love them i've seen some pics
from the office during unboxing and it's
just wild how excited everyone gets this
one
oh my god plus every time you get your
box in the mail you can feel good
knowing that you're supporting family
businesses all the way in japan so if
you want to get your own box suit and
enjoy your own midori moment click the
link in the description and use the code
rockstar to get 15 off your order at
dinner yusuf says that's why we moved to
america right so that our children could
be anything that they wanted to be
almost anything
yes this is the common hope of all
immigrants but might have a deeper
context if anima doesn't want kamala to
be a cosmically powered inhuman yusuf
goes on to say muniba's family moved to
karachi only after the partition back
then there was no pakistan all
bangladesh it was all one big country
india after the british system the
british left us with a mess so the
partition refers to when great britain
parted ways with british india in 1947
and the subcontinent divided into india
and pakistan separating the military the
civil service railways treasury millions
of people along religious lines muslims
to pakistan hindus to india displacing
10 to 20 million people causing horrible
ethnic violence resulting in deaths
estimated from several hundred thousand
people to two million people it was a
horrible dark time one of the worst
refugee crises we've seen in human
history yusuf explains how manipu's
mother was caught up in all that a
toddler on the last train out of a
station and got separated from her
parents nobody knows how a little
toddler
managed to get back on the train just
before the train pulled out of the
station i like how amir completes this
part of the story but then yusuf turns
to kamala to finish the second part of
the story about how the toddler made it
back to her father she followed a trail
of stars
right back to her father
[Music]
i like how there's some subtle musical
chimes here like it was some cosmic
magic at play in this history a trail of
stars referring to cosmic intervention
cree tech inhumans that sana and her
mother aisha use to survive maybe even a
cree starship transporting her back to
her father trail of stars also sounds
like something america chavez might have
helped out with using a path of star
portals to teleport santa back to her
father now this would have been almost
80 years prior i'm not really sure how
aging works in other dimensions like the
utopian parallel but it's just worth
bringing up trail of stars you know but
when yusuf mentions that maniva's mother
disappeared the bangle glows a white
portal opens and kamala's eyes glow
purple as they did last episode when she
was transported to that other realm in
this case a woman appears with a purple
tinted face and this is neymar boucha's
character credited as najma i'm thinking
also kamala's great-grandmother aisha
that kamala's nani aisha's daughter said
previously owned this bangle and the
purple color on her face could make her
one of those purple entities from
kamala's vision i believe all of them
representing aisha's other inhuman
family and kamala's broader ancestry
network but listen closely to the sound
effects here you can hear a train
whistle
there is also the sound of a train under
najma in the back seat in the final shot
both of these train sounds could be not
to aisha getting separated from sana and
sana's father at that train station and
aisha later helping sana find him using
that trail of stars now later in this
episode the illuminatis will goss about
aisha my father called her a snake she
put a curse on everything she touched i
heard that she had a secret affair and
took off with someone i heard she had
many affairs and she had a secret family
i heard she killed a man happened dating
partition yes just some hot goss of
course but it might be rooted in truth
just from a different point of view like
aisha may have had another family of
inhumans she might have killed someone
in self-defense and her powers back then
probably were viewed as a curse or some
kind of superstition i just love how
this series grounds kamala's family
history in the partition between india
and pakistan real world history when
many lives were lost many families were
separated and many at that point in
history were ostracized as others
something that could apply doubly to
aisha as an inhuman in the 40s that
would stir up these rumors and
superstitions about her in that
community leading her just getting
separated during the partition and
letting her family go so they could have
a normal life yet still an inhuman gene
would have been left in the women of
this family a legacy that moniva fears
as a curse feeling shame over it but now
kamala has it and it has been activated
they attend the eid festival at their
mosque or eat elada kamala jokes with
nakia and bruno about the illuminati's
the illuminati's actually they know
everything we later meet them and
nakia's breakdown of the different
groups of this community which is just
pretty interesting timing for multiverse
of madness to introduce us to the 838
illuminati i would love it if this is
the illuminati of the 616 universe and
here in the animated title the a is the
all-seeing eye of the illuminati
conspiracy theory we also meet the
mosque bros which actually includes a
cameo by bill alfalah the co-director of
episode one in episode six then the
pious boys have the same hands together
image as kamala's bismala drawing in
episode 1 but notice how the hands
separate to reflect that gap that nakia
refers to and then the insta click has
instagram labels like tag blast dean
dean being a term in islam for staying
devout under allah then dodc agent
cleary interrogates zoe you're not the
zoe zimmer the only one i know what you
have got to be kidding me i'm a big fan
wait really yes everyone in the office
is yeah cleary knows that flattery is
everything to you suspects similar to
how he's able to get ned to confess his
role in no way home but of course his
tone shifts and then the uh enhanced
individual tried to kill you aha
enhanced that was the code term that the
mcu used in place of mutants back in age
of ultron in this case it seems to be a
catch-all term for any rogue
superpowered person mutant inhuman super
soldier hulk anyone beneath the tier of
sam wilson's big three black big three
androids aliens and wizards but then
agent deaver joins interrogation and uh
did she have an accent of any kind was
she latino
i'm sorry i'm supposed to say
latinx now right middle eastern
south asian yeah clara's expression
suggests he objects to this kind of
racial profiling but then he says let's
do the tri-state sweep search every
temple community center and
and mosque just be respectful
the fbi is already surveilling let me
know that
they do leave ariane moyad off screen
but you can hear in his delivery a bit
of hesitation right before he says
mosque and then they include the mention
of the fbi because yeah since 9 11 the
fbi has been monitoring mosques in
muslim community centers all over the
country a shift from the bureau's focus
on domestic terrorism in the 90s after
the oklahoma city bombings and wouldn't
you know it that white nationalism
didn't go anywhere at the festival a kid
hangs from the tower so kamala has to
suit up and cosplay to save him i love
how she tries to calm him down
do you have a favorite food ice cream
pizza did someone say ice cream pizza i
love how the shop the vendor just got an
idea for a new food to sell this guy
better be selling ice cream pizza next
episode kamala lilly pads over to him
and tries to catch him but when the hard
light gives out she has to form another
landing pad saving the day we think
hopping off forming another pose just
like her fantasy self did in episode 1
copying black widow we see a frenzy of
social media posts about this rescue
also commenting on the hilarious
combination of pizza and ice cream i'd
love all these memes but they include
one from frogman jewels and we will see
frogman and she-hulk eugene patillo as
that goofball in the spring-loaded frog
suit that he got from his father this
angle of this photo of kamala falling is
from above with the hard light below her
so frogman must have been leaping over
them to get this photo of this moment
doing nothing to save them but then
again we also don't know if these memes
are actually in real life or just
kamala's imagination and how she thinks
everyone will love her because of this
probably the latter but kamala's
concentration is broken when her
great-grandmother appears to her so the
hard light flickers out and the kid
falls again kamala's in big hand fails
to catch him so she has to slow his fall
with just more hard platforms leading to
a pretty hard landing
oh come on kid you already know it's
your angle kid's trying to get kamala
yellow card kamala faces a drone that
looks like a dark painted customized
stark drone from spider-man far from
home and no way home also cameo to
multiverse madness remember that that
was weird now remember the dodc and
other agencies confiscated these drones
so they would be in possession of them
but they don't necessarily have full
control over tony's edith software which
might be why the drone's inner interface
looks different than it did and far from
home devers shows up with dodc agents
armed with these handheld sonic cannons
this should look familiar to you this is
more stark tech first seen in the 2008
hulk film it was a stark industry's
design when they used it on the virginia
campus but tony also added these to war
machines armor and civil war when he
used it on wanda maximoff these were
also on the stark drones and far from
home blowing peter off of tower bridge
and we see these same guns in the
she-hulk trailer suggesting it is the
dodc there in that show also a crazy
detail in episode one if you're looking
closely looks like there is a photo of
jamila jamil on the dodc's wanted
posters in that post-credits scene jamil
is playing the super villain titania in
she-hulk so since we see these guns in
the she-hulk trailer that might mean the
dodc is the same agency that jennifer
walters is dealing with in that series
and if matt murdock dealt with the dodc
and no way home it's just one more way
daredevil could cross over into she-hulk
it's all connected kamala wrecks these
drones just as effectively as peter
parker did but the sonic cannon
obliterates her hard light making it
look so brittle and i think this hard
light is actually meant to look wrinkled
and creased to deliberately evoke paper
mache as if this is glowing paper mache
as kamala's powers were activated while
she was wearing paper mache captain
marvel cosplay as i explained in my
video where i interviewed the directors
this form of kamala's powers is intended
to be a temporary look that kamala will
evolve past and i think this hard light
is really pieces of her terrigen cocoon
that she's gradually shedding off until
she reaches her final form cameron's
timing is amazing as he swoops in to
pick her up but in the back seat is a
ghost kamala
i've been waiting a very long time to
meet you
it's all connected oh because if najma
aka the woman from the visions is
kamala's great grandmother aisha if
she's also cameron's mother that would
make cameron kamala's grandmother's
brother or half-brother if he was born
with a different father but still
cameron might be kamala's grand uncle
thor hook up kamala with an escape here
he's adopted now of course it is very
odd that najma is still relatively young
if she's her great-grandmother from the
40s she should be older right well najma
may instead just be a sister or cousin
to miniva who just looks a lot like
their great-grandmother might still be a
relative that moniva left behind in
pakistan who in that case would make
cameron kamala's cousin but no i don't
think so najma looks exactly the same
with these visions and in those visions
she wore older clothes had an older
hairstyle so i think najma is the same
person as aisha and the agelessness is
because she is an inhuman the curse that
the illuminati's were talking about
najma and kamran might be inhumans and
humans are known to live two to three
times longer than humans are age more
slowly now i know you might say eternals
don't age at all and cameron did mention
najma liked kingo movies i just doubt
that these characters would be ideal as
eternals as well there were only 10
eternals on the planet they were
synthetic aliens they don't really
reproduce or anything i really just
think najma liked kingo because she
identified another ageless figure hiding
in public of course another possibility
to consider is that najma might just be
a scroll taking on the identity of
ayesha's appearance the rumors that she
was a snake could come from aisha having
a skrull partner that she would trade
places with the way fury and talos have
a partnership since in the comics
cameron actually serves a villain called
lineage najma here might be this show's
version of that character it just
remains to be seen whether she is truly
villainous or someone who's actually
trying to help her but also we should
point out carol danvers cosmic power up
and ensuing cree transfusions left her
in a state in which she didn't really
age from 1995 to 2023 so all of this
might just be a symptom of cree tech and
cosmic radiation and i just think it's
so ironic that kamala began this episode
joking about how like ant-man she looks
younger than she really is and now that
seems to be a genetic trait that she
inherited that is everything i spotted
in episode 2 of miss marvel check me out
on instagram and twitter at eavos follow
me rockstar subscribe to new york stars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you